THE COMMITTEE ON NATURAL
RESOURCES AND WATER WILL COME TO
ORDER GOOD MORNING IN RESPONSE
THE COVER NINETEEN EMERGENCY TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WHO MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES APPLY TO
THESE ORDERS THE SENATE IS MADE
IT NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO
NORMAL PRACTICES IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THE PUBLIC CONTINUE TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. WE'RE HOLDING OUR
HEARINGS HERE IN THE- STREET
BUILDING S. THAT ALL MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE PRESIDENT RAM TWENTY
ONE HUNDRED SO WE CAN ESTABLISH
A QUORUM WHICH WE NOW HAVE A
BEGINNER HEARING TO ALLOW THE
PUBLIC ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
HEARING ROOM TO THE EXTENT THAT
SOCIAL DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS
ALLOWING WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE TODAY FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY. FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT DEPARTMENT TOLL FREE
NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED
ON THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE BE
SPLIT ON THE SCREEN ALL
ANNOUNCES THAT. THE PARTICIPATE
NUMBER IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN TWO
TWO SIX EIGHT ONE SIX THREE. AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS SEVEN THREE
SIX TWO EIGHT THREE THREE. FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO
THE TELECONFERENCES TO WORST
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE AND-
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WE WERE MOVED
TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU'LL BE
PROMPTED BY MODERATOR. TO DIAL
ONE NINE ZERO FOR SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION. PRESS THERE'S ONLY
ONE TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR
AN OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER THIS CAN BE A SHORT WAIT.
ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER YOU WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR
THE MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER. THAT TIME YOU'LL BE
AMUSING YOU'RE NOW READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY INTO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU MUST NEED
THE DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING
HEARING. ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT'S
IMPORTANT WE HEAR FROM YOU WE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE. ALL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY
IN ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO IS
DISRUPTIVE. MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE OR
HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED. SO
WITH THAT MEMBERS WE HAVE NINE
BILLS ON THE AGENDA- FOREIGN
PROPOSED CONSENT. ON FILE ITEM
FIVE WILL BE HEARD AT OUR NEXT
HEARING. AND OF FILE ITEMS ONE
TWO THREE AND SIX ARE CURRENTLY
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR. OF THE
BEFORE YOUR PRESENTATION ON THE
BILLS WHICH STEPS TO QUORUM.
CHIEF CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. STERN HERE STERN HERE
JONES ALLEN ALLEN HERE EGGMAN
EGGMAN HERE GROVE BIRDS BIRD
HERTZBERG HERE HUESO HERE HUESO
HERE WHERE HERE LARRY HEARING
ALONE. OKAY QUORUM IS
ESTABLISHED I AM HEARING A
MOTION FROM MY COLLEAGUES YES I
MOVED THE CONSENT CALENDAR SO
THAT'S A MOTION FROM SENATOR
LAYERED ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
THAT'S AGAIN MEMBERS ITEMS ONE
TWO THREE AND SIX- CHIEF
CONSULTANT WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR TURN BY TURN ALL RIGHT
JONES ALLEN. ALLEN HI EGGMAN
EGGMAN ALL RIGHT GROVE HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG ALL RIGHT HUESO HUESO
IRATE LAYERED HI THERE ALL RIGHT
LET ALONE. OKAY VERY GOOD AT THE
MEASURE SIX VOTES WILL LEAVE IT
ON CALL FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS
NOTES HERE FROM OUR FIRST AUTHOR
WELCOME CENTER KAMAGRA THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND I KNOW
YOU'RE HERE TO PRESENT SB TEN
FIFTY TWO FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR
SO- PLEASE PROCEED AT YOUR- AT
YOUR- CONVENIENCE. THANK YOU ALL
GOOD MORNING SHARE AND MEMBERS.
AND THIS IS MY FIRST TIME HERE
THIS IS FABULOUS. SO I AM HERE
TO PRESENT SB TEN FIFTY TWO.
THIS BILL EXPANDS AND PROTECTS
THE BALDWIN HILLS CONSERVANCY
PROVIDING ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
FOR COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE FACED
HISTORIC DISINVESTMENT. THE
BALDWIN HILLS CONSERVANCY WAS
CREATED BY THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE IN TWO THOUSAND. AND
ITS MISSION IS TO PRESERVE OPEN
SPACE AND HABITAT WHILE
FACILITATING PUBLIC ACCESS TO
CALIFORNIA'S WILDERNESS AND
WILDLIFE. SB TEN FIFTY TWO
EXPANDS THE BOUNDARIES OF THE
CONSERVANCY TO INCLUDE THE
SOUTHERN BY ON A CREEK WATERSHED
IN UPPER DOMINGUEZ CHANNEL AREA
CHANGES THE NAME TO THE BALDWIN
HILLS AND URBAN WATERSHEDS
CONSERVANCY ACT AND REPEALS THE
JANUARY ONE TWENTY TWENTY SIX
SUNSET DATE. THE BALDWIN HILLS
AREA IS ONE OF THE LARGEST IS
THE ONE OF THE LAST LARGE OPEN
SPACES IN URBAN L. A. COUNTY.
THE BALDWIN HILLS CONSERVANCY IS
WITH IN THE COUNTY OF LOS
ANGELES AND CITIES OF LOS
ANGELES IN CULVER CITY IT COVERS
NEARLY TWO SQUARE MILES OF
UNDERDEVELOPED LAND MOST OF
WHICH IS PRIVATELY OWNED OIL
WELLS. BUT ALSO CONTAINS THE
FIVE HUNDRED ACRE KENNY HAN
STATE RECREATION AREA WEST LOS
ANGELES COLLEGE IN HOLY CROSS
CEMETERY. WHILE THE CONSERVANCY
HAS SUCCESSFULLY COMPLETED OVER
SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS WORTH OF
IMPROVEMENT PROJECTS WITHIN ITS
TERRITORY SEVERAL NEIGHBORING
AND NEARBY COMMUNITIES IN NEED
HAVE NOT HAD DIRECT ACCESS TO
THE SAME PLANNING AND
DEVELOPMENT OPPORTUNITIES. IN
THE ABSENCE OF A DEDICATED
CONSERVANCY IN THE URBANIZED
REGIONS OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
SEVERAL KEY LEGISLATIVE
DISTRICTS CITIES AND PORTIONS OF
UNINCORPORATED. COUNTY HAVE
ESSENTIALLY BEEN OMITTED FROM
ACCESSING PASSED STATE GRANT
WATERSHED BASED PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES OFFERED THROUGH BOND
INITIATIVES THE BALDWIN HILLS
CONSERVANCY EXPANSION INTO THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA BY ON A
CREEK WATERSHED AND UPPER
DOMINGUEZ CHANNEL AREA WILL HELP
THESE AREAS ACCESS AND QUALIFY.
FOR FUTURE BOND FUNDS WHILE
PRESERVING CALIFORNIA'S NATURAL
RESOURCES. WITH ME IN SUPPORT
TODAY IS LUCAS FREAK FRIEDRICHS
. WITH YES THAT PART WITH THE
NEED MORNING AFTER CHAIRED
SENATORS- THIS I THE
CONSTRUCTION AN INTERPRETER YEAH
I'M SORRY WE WERE UNABLE TO HEAR
CENTER COME UNDER YOUR FOR
TESTIMONY SO- BUT UNSURE WHEN TO
START MY APOLOGIES YOU'RE GONNA
START IGHT IN THE SECOND AND SO
MY HERNANDEZ WITH THE SOUTH LA
TRANSIT EMPOWER MEN DON'T SO
LUCAS NOW YOU CAN GO OUT. THANK
YOU SENATOR GOVERNOR
INTERRUPTING YOU I WE ARE. YOUR
TESTIMONY SO I'M SURE GREAT.
MORNING ADVOCATES. FOR AND GIVEN
THE MORNING OF A FOR A NATURE
WE'RE PROUD TO BE HERE THIS
MORNING TO TENDER COME ON AT TEN
K. TO THE OF ALL THOSE. AND
WE'RE FORTUNATE TO WORK CLOSE
WITH MANY OF STATE CONSERVE
RECORDING WHAT WOULD THEM PUBLIC
HEALTH HAS BEEN HARD AT
INCLUDING PROJECTS PRESERVE
RESTORE Y. HABIT IN WATERSHED BY
LITTLE IN CREATION WITH A USES.
IF THE LAST TWO YEARS DEALING
WITH THE CALL THE PANDEMIC
TAUGHT US ANYTHING IT'S THAT THE
ACCESS TO THE OUTDOORS AND
CENTRAL TO MENTAL HALTH WELL
BEING IT MAY BE EVEN MORE
IMPORTANT URBAN AREAS WHERE
EVERYTHING OPEN SPACE AND ACCESS
TO NATURE ARE MORE PREMIUM THE
PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS MAY BE
SMALL BUT IT'S MIGHTY AND
ADDRESSES KIND THE IMPACT AND
IMPROVE QUALITY OF LIFE BY
INCREASING ACCESS TO MAJOR.
CLEANING OUR WATER ENGAGING
COMMITTEES DIRECTLY WHAT ABOUT
HELP CONSERVANCY HAS
SUCCESSFULLY COMPLETED NUMEROUS
PROJECTS WITH ITS TERRITORY
SEVERAL NEIGHBORING AND NEARBY
COMMUNITIES HAVE NOT HAD ACCESS
TO THE SAME OPPORTUNITIES
EXPANDING GLOBAL HEALTH
CONSERVANCY WOULD PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES FOR
COMMUNITIES. THAT HAD FACED
HISTORIC DISINVESTMENT. SHE
LEADERSHIP BY COM ON THIS. ISSUE
IN WHICH THE ASK YOUR I. BOATS.
THANK YOU MUCH WE WILL OTHER
LEAD WITNESS- IS SHE THE LINE I
THINK IT'S MS HERNANDEZ. YES YES
WELCOME TO THINK PLEASE PROCEED
. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING CHAIR
NUMBERS MY NAME IS SUMMER
HERNANDEZ AND I'M THE DIRECTOR
OF QUALITY IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE SOUTH OF FRANCE IF TRANSIT
EMPOWERMENT DON'T FIRSTLY HE-
NEW YORK CITY THAT THE COURT AT
THE COMPLEXITY TO. FLAYED THE
ETHNICALLY SPEAKING AND COLLECT
IN AFTER WHOSE WORK LATE AT THE
INTER OF ECONOMIC REVITALIZATION
AND ENVIRONMENT THE ABILITY OUR
PRIMARY SERVING AS THE BACKBONE
REPORTER FEDERICA SIXTY EIGHT
SOUTH LUCK ON THIS PROMISE
DON'T. WHICH AREA IS HOME TO
NEARLY TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
RESIDENTS WHO HAVE BEEN
HISTORICALLY DIFFERENT FRANCHISE
BY THE DECADES OF REDLINING
PRACTICES DE INDUSTRIALIZATION
AND DISINVESTMENT 31% OF OUR
RESIDENTS LIVE BELOW THE FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVEL AND NINE POINT 1%
EXPERIENCE UNEMPLOYMENT. VIOLENT
CRIME IN SOUTH LOS ANGELES IT'S
DOUBLE THAT THE WHITE RATE
FURTHER EXACERBATING THESE
ISSUES THE SOUTH OF THE PROMISE
ZONE IS ONE OF THE MOST POLLUTED
AREAS IN CALIFORNIA WE KNOW OUR
COMMUNITY NEEDS MORE GREEN
SPACE. AND ACCESS TO EXISTING
GREEN SPACE THE FOLLOWING YEAR
CONSERVANCY IS A VITAL COMMUNITY
ASSET IT'S PRETTY THREE THEN
THAT'S GREAT WE HAVE BEEN
INVOLVED IN COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT
EFFORTS. TO REPEAL THE JANUARY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY SIX AND
FIFTY AND EXPAND THE CONSERVANCY
FOUNDRY SB TEN FIFTY TWO
ADDRESSES CLIMATE IMPACT AND
IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF LIFE. FOR
SELF APPOINTED ITS RESIDENT. THE
NEW YORK. YOUR OF CONLOGUE AND
URGES THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATOR
VOTE AND AT AT TEN FIFTY TWO AND
FURTHER PROMOTE HOW EQUITY. A
GLOBAL DEGREE SPACES AND WHAT IT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MS
HERNANDEZ FRUIT. IN YOUR ADVERT-
ONE MOVE ON TO ONE TO TEST IN
SUPPORT- FROM HERE ROOM DO WE
HAVE ANY. WITH THE IN SUPPORT IN
THE HEARING ROOM SEEING NINE-
WILL TURN TO THE TELECONFERENCE
ERVAS MODERATOR IF YOU'D PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WE NEED
TESTIFYING SUPPORT THIS BE TEN
FIFTY TWO WE CAN BEGIN. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO- IF
YOU WISH TO MAKE A COMMENT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. THANKS AGAIN FOR ANY
COMMENT IN THE COURT OF SB ONE
ZERO FIVE TWO CREEK PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE
BEEN CUT QUEUING UP PLEASE WAIT
FOR THEM TO BE ASSIGNED A NUMBER.
COMMENT FROM NINE TWENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
TURN MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
NIKITA KARATE WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL
CALLING FOR PARKS. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANKS WITH THIS. WATER DO
WE HAVE ANY OTHERS WISHING HAS
TO FIND SUPPORT ON THE LINE. NO
THERE'S NO NOTHING TO SUPPORT
OKAY- SEEING NONE ELSE IN THE
ROOM MORE ON THE LINE- WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO OPPOSITION WE DON'T
HAVE ANY- LISTED OPPOSITION
HERE- BUT IF THERE'S ANYONE IN
THE ROOM WISHING TESTIFIED
OPPOSITION TO SB TEN FIFTY TO
PLEASE COME FORWARD SEEING NINE
WILL TURN THE LINES MODERATOR
WOULD YOU MIND PROMPTING
INDIVIDUALS BEEN TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION SB TEN FIFTY TWO. IF
THERE ARE ANY. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION OF SB TEN FIFTY TWO
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN A POSITION OF
S. B. AND FIFTY TWO YOU MAY
PRESS ONE. AND THEN TO. WE HAVE
NO COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION OKAY
YOU CAN FIFTY TWO VERY GOOD
THANK YOU SO MUCH I WILL TURN
BACK TO THE DIS HERE MEMBERS
COMMENTS QUESTIONS. YES CENTER
LAYERED THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
ARM. ET IT'S BEEN AN INTERESTING
HISTORY BECAUSE OF THE ROUGHLY
TEN STATE CONSERVANCY'S. THERE
ARE SOME THAT ARE REALLY SMALL.
AND THERE ARE SOME THAT ARE
MONUMENTALLY LARGE AND- WHEN I
WAS CHAIR OF THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
COMMITTEE I TRUSTED WITH SENATOR
CALM WATERS PREDECESSOR. OF
SENATOR MURRAY WHO WANTED THE
EXACT SAME AMOUNT OF MONEY FOR
THE BALDWIN HILLS CONSERVANCY.
TWO SQUARE MILES OR WHATEVER IT
IS AND THE SIERRA NEVADA
CONSERVANCY WHICH IS. I THINK
THREE MILLION ACRES. IN OUR-
THIS HAPPENS TO BE ONE OF THREE
BILLS THAT IS ON OUR AGENDA
TODAY- THAT EXPANDS THE
BOUNDARIES OF CONSERVANCIES AND
LAST YEAR SENATOR DOLLY. R. AS
SENATOR HUESO IS BEING MOVED- I
JUST DIDN'T UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
UPROAR WAS KNEW IT WASN'T MY COM
- BUT LAST YEAR SENATOR DOLLY
DID A BILL THAT EXPANDED THIS
YEAR CONSERVANCY AND SO WE'RE
MOVING INTO A PERIOD. WHERE
PARTICULARLY WITH THE SMALLER
ONES HA I THINK THE FOCUS OF A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF MONEY IN A
REAL SMALL SPACES AS RUN ITS
COURSE AND SOIT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO EXPAND IT AND DO
THE FOCUS. IN IN THIS CASE IT IS
REALLY WITH DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND THAT IS REALLY
THE RIGHT. OUR DIRECTION SO- I
APPLAUD THE AUTHOR FOR DOING THE
BILL I'M PREPARED TO SUPPORT ALL
THREE OF THESE BECAUSE I THINK
EVERYONE EXPANDING A CONSERVE
THE BOUNDARY. THE IN A SMALLER
CONSERVANCY MAKES TOTAL SENSE
AND AT THE APPROPRIATE MOMENT I
DO WANT TO MOVE. IT'S BETTER
THAN. WE'LL TAKE THAT AS A
MOTION FROM CENTER LATER BUT
OTHERS WHICH ANY COMMENTS AND
ARE EGGMAN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AS CHAIR OF. I'M A HUGE FAN
GREEN SPACE AND THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD I'M ASKING
EVERYBODY ABOUT EVERYTHING NOW
HAS ALREADY BEEN EVALUATED FOR
HOUSING BECAUSE AS MUCH AS I
LIKE OPEN SPACE- I KNOW WE'RE
ALSOALL STRUGGLING WITH.
FINDING NEW NEW GROUNDS FOR
PEOPLE TO BE ABLE TO DEVELOP AND
LIVE ON- SO I JUST I JUST WONDER
ON THIS CASE AND EVERY OTHER
ONE. IF THERE'S ALREADY BEEN
SOME KIND OF EVALUATION ABOUT
THE- THE- THE POSSIBILITY OF
BEING ABLE TO INTEGRATE ANY
KIND. OF HOUSING. WHEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT EXPANDING
BOUNDARIES OF SPACE. AS AN
EITHER OR- EITHER OR BOTH. I'M
SO I THINK I HAVE TO GET BACK TO
YOU ON THAT I HAVE BEEN IN
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE BALDWIN
HILLS CONSERVANCY ABOUT THIS
PARTICULAR EXPANSION TERRITORY
AND NO ONE HAS TALKED ABOUT
HOUSING I DO ALSO KNOW THAT-
THEY COUNTY- AND PARTNERS WITH
THE CONSERVANCY HAVE ALSO BEEN
VERY INTERESTED IN- UNDER
DEVELOPED NON GREEN SPACE FOR
HOUSING AND HOW TO TRANSITION
EITHER UNDER UTILIZED- LIGHT
INDUSTRIAL OR LIGHT COMMERCIAL.
ARM BUT I'D LOVE TO BE ABLE TO
JUST YOU KNOW GIVE YOU A
DEFINITIVE ANSWER YEAH THIS IS
LONGER ARE WE JUST THINKING
ABOUT THIS ALL THINK ABOUT WE
ARE DEFINITELY DOING ABOUT IT IN
MY DISTRICT- 70% RENTERS HIGH
LEVELS OF AFFORDABILITY. AND
ALSO SORT OF MARRYING THAT WITH
A LACK OF GREEN SPACE YEAH BOTH
HUGELY HUGELY IMPORTANT ISSUES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
CENTER EGGMAN OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE MEMBERS- YES
CENTER ALLEN. I JUST WANNA LEARN
THE- THE COMMITTEE- I HAVE A
BILL ON ANOTHER CONSERVANCY THIS
ADJACENT TO THE ONE THAT I SENT
TO CONGRESS PRESENTED TO DATE
THERE ACTUALLY IS A PROPOSED
OVERLAP SO THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
HAS TO GET WORKED OUT AND THAT
REPRESENTS FROM THE TWO
CONSERVATIVES ARE GOING TO BE
DISCUSSING AND FIGURE THIS OUT
WITH WITH SUPPORT CORP
INCORPORATION FROM THE COMMITTEE
SO. JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT
EVERYONE HIS AWARE AND- THAT'S
THAT'S THAT'S- THAT'S BEING
WORKED OUT WITH THAT I'D I'D
LOVE TO INTO THE ETHICALLY MOVE
THE ITEM OKAY- WILL BE WORKED
OUT. IT WILL BE WORKED OUT
THROUGH. WE OBSERVE A MOTION
FROM STERLING BUT WILL SAY THAT
IT IS A DOUBLE MOTION OF THESE
YES STICK SUPPORT FROM SENATOR
ALAN- BUT I WOULD JUST SAY JOHN
WAS LESS ENTHUSIASTIC. HE
BROUGHT OUT ALL THE ISSUES
SERVANT IF THE AUTHORIZES WE
HAVEN'T DONE ALLEN BILL YET HAVE
. WE'RE A NATION OF MYSELF. I
HAD TOO MUCH COFFEE THIS
MORNING- SO. I'LL BE SUPPORTING
IS MEASURES WELL AND I THINK YOU
KNOW. THIS PART OF LOS ANGELES
IS FOR TOO LONG BEEN OVERLOOKED
IS A PLACE THAT. OPEN SPACE IS
POSSIBLE AND THAT WILD PLACES
ARE POSSIBLE AND THAT SOMEHOW
THAT OUGHT TO BE ONLY RELEGATED
TO SAY THE SANTA MONICA
MOUNTAINS OR THE SANTA SUSANNA
MOUNTAINS- THIS HISTORIC
WATERSHED THAT THE EXPANSION IS
GOING TO ENTAIL- HAS BEEN OPEN
SPACE. AND WE SORT OF DENIED IT
IT'S NATURAL USE- BY PAVING OVER
A LOT OF THIS WATER SHOULD WE
THINK THERE'S GOING TO BE
SUBSTANTIAL OPPORTUNITIES FOR.
NOT JUST INFILL DEVELOPMENT AND
THE KIND OF HOUSING WE NEED BUT
A RIGHT TO NATURE FOR THESE
COMMUNITIES TO SO THAT WHEN YOU
MOVE IN YOU'RE NOT GONNA LIVE IN
A BIGGER BEEN HEAT ISLAND. I
THINK IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT THAT
WE RECOGNIZE THAT THIS-
CESSATION OF A SUNSET THE THIS
IS THE ONLY CONSERVANCY
OPERATING IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA RIGHT NOW WITH THAT
KIND OF SUNSET DATE ON IT. DON'T
SEE WHY WE'RE TREATING IT AS A
TWO TIERED SYSTEM SO I THINK
IT'S HIGH TIME THAT. WE WE PUT
THIS CONSERVANCY ON ON EVEN
FOOTING WITH THE REST OF THE
STATE- SO I APPRECIATE YOU
BRINGING IT FORWARD CENTER AND-
I LOOK FORWARD TO THE MEASURE
BEING SORTED THROUGH I HAVE ONE
MORE COMMENT FROM SENATOR ALAN
I'M SO SORRY I JUST WANT TO
POINT OUT I WENT I HAD A GREAT
CHANCE TO GO WITH MY WIFE AND
KIDS- TO THE TOP OF- THE BALDWIN
HILLS. JUST A COUPLE MONTHS AGO
DURING DURING THE RECESS AND IF
FOR THE MEMBERS WHO ARE NOT FROM
LOS ANGELES WHO HAVEN'T HAD A
CHANCE TO GO VISIT THIS AREA.
IT'S EXTRAORDINARY I MEAN THAT
THERE'S PEOPLE FROM ALL WALKS OF
LIFE HIKING UP IN THIS IN THIS
THIS LITTLE LITTLE PIECE LITTLE
TINY PIECE OF WILDERNESS RIGHT
SURROUNDED BY THE SECOND LARGEST
CITY IN THE COUNTRY- AND- IT YOU
KNOW IN IN ONE OF OUR MORE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
IT'S A VERY SPECIAL AREA I WAS
I'M I'M EXCITED ABOUT WHAT THIS
IS GOING TO. ENTAIL FOR THE
URBAN RESIDENTS OF THIS AREA
IT'S YOU KNOW IT IT IS A IT'S A
IT'S A REAL GIFT. AND I THINK
IT'S GOING TO PAY DIVIDENDS FOR
FUTURE GENERATIONS. YES THANK
YOU FOR THE ADDED A- THE ONE
OTHER POINT I WAS JUST GONNA
MAKING CALLS AND BEFORE ALLOWING
YOU TO CLOSE YOUR SENATORS THAT.
I BELIEVE THERE'S BEEN SOME
SUBSTANTIAL ANALYSIS ALSO IN THE
BIO DIVERSITY BENEFITS. OF THIS.
SORT OF MICRO PRO JUST
IMPLEMENTING THIRTY BY THIRTY AN
OPEN SPACE REQUIREMENTS WITHIN
THE STATE- WE THINK THERE'S
VALUE. NOT JUST IN QUANTITY. BUT
IN QUALITY WHEN IT COMES TO
HABITAT LINKAGES IN THE OTHER
SORT OF CORE FUNCTIONS HERE SO.
ANYHOW THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD- AND LOOK FORTY
GETTING INSTEAD WILL ALLOW YOU
TO CLOSE YOUR AND YOUR CONVENE.
WELL AT THE RISK OF OFFENDING
THE CLOTHES THAT I THINK SENATOR
ALLEN OFFERED- WHICH WAS PRETTY
SPECIAL I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT
THIS IS AN AMAZING- PART OF THE
CITY IN AN UNINCORPORATED PART
OF THE COUNTY- IT IS A SPACE
WHERE FRIENDS HAVE GONE AND HAVE
SEEN BOBCATS AND ALL OTHER KINDS
OF SPECIAL WILDLIFE THAT YOU
WERE NOT EXPECTING TO SEE AN
URBAN LOS ANGELES. IT IS A- PART
OF THE COUNTY THAT IS USED BY
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
RESIDENTS AND ALSO TOURISTS FROM
ALL OVER THE WORLD AND THIS WILL
AFFORD- THIS SPACE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GO AFTER NEEDED
FUNDS TO CONTINUE TO CREATE AND
BUILD A SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND
CALIFORNIA THAT WE WANT ALL OF
OUR RESIDENTS SO I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CLOTHES AND WE HAVE A
MOTION FROM SENATOR LAYERED- THE
MOTION IS TO PASS- BUT FIRST RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS- CHIEF CONSULT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. FILE ITEM
FOR S. B. TEN FIFTY TWO MOTIONS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS EARNED
HI STERN ALRIGHT JONES. JONES
AYE ALLEN. ALLEN I EGGMAN.
EGGMAN ALL RIGHT GROVE.
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG HIGHWAY SO.
HUESO AYE LAYERED AYE LAYERED
AYE LIMÓN. LIMÓN ALL RIGHT. THE
MEASURE IS EIGHT VOTES- WE WILL
LEAVE IT ON CALL FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS NO WE'RE SAYING NO THERE-ARE NO ABSENT MEMBERS WERE FULL
OKAY SO THE MEASURE PASSES THANK
YOU SO MUCH- WILL MOVE ON TO OUR
NEXT ITEM HERE- FILE ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN- SENATOR ACTUALLY DO WE
HAVE ANY. NON THE PRO TEM HERE
TO ME OKAY. I'M HERE LET'S GO IN
ORDER THEN- SENATE ALLEN DO YOU
MIND WELL- SO THE KIDS HE
CONTROLLERS CAN IS IT IS
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF THE
SITE IS NOT AVAILABLE TO TEN I
COULD DO MY NEXT BILL FIRST IF
WHEN WE DO THAT WHEN WE GO TO
FILE ITEM EIGHT. AND THEN IF
YOU'RE READY WILL PULL FLIP BACK
TO SEVEN OTHERWISE WE'LL PROCEED
TO FILE ITEM NINE OKAY SO YOU
HAVE- YES BACK TO BACK
CONSERVANCY- SB ELEVEN TWENTY
TWO MEMBERS FILE ITEM EIGHT.
UNDER YOUR FROM MY SEAT. SO IS
THE FACT THAT CLIMATE CHANGE
THREATEN CALIFORNIA'S NATURAL
ENVIRONMENTS I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE CONTINUE TO DO
THIS WORK THAT WE'VE JUST BEEN
DISCUSSING IT WITH CONSENT OF
CONGRESS BILL PROTECTING OUR
WILDERNESS IN MY LIFE WHERE WE
CAN INCLUDING. IN OUR URBAN
AREAS ARE NATURE CONSERVANCY'S
SERVE A VITAL ROLE IN ACHIEVING
THAT GOAL- THE LOWER LOS ANGELES
RIVERS AND MOUNTAINS CONSERVANCY
IS ONE OF TEN STATEWIDE
CONSERVANCY IS TASKED WITH
PRESERVING OPEN SPACE IN
FACILITATING PUBLIC ACCESS TO
OUR STATE'S WILDERNESS AND
WILDLIFE IT'S AN ART THIS IS
ACHIEVED THROUGH GROUP GRANT
PROJECTS THAT OFFER LOW IMPACT
RECREATIONAL AND EDUCATIONAL
ACTIVITIES THAT BENEFIT THE
SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES WE'VE
JUST BEEN DISCUSSING. THIS IS A
PARTICULAR CONSERVANCY THIS
RIVERS AMOUNTS CONSERVANCY SERVE
COMMUNITIES WITHIN THEIR
EXISTING TERRITORY FOR OVER TWO
DECADES. AND THERE THERE ARE
NEARBY AREAS THAT HAVE NOT
BENEFITED FROM THE SAME
WILDERNESS PRESERVATION
RECREATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES IN
THIS BILL IS GOING TO ENHANCE
CONSERVATION AND PUBLIC
RECREATION. IN MORE COMMUNITIES
BY EXPANDING THE TERRITORY OF
THE RMC TO INCLUDE THE DEMANDES
CHANNEL WATERSHED SANTA CATALINA
ISLAND AND COASTAL AREA
WATERSHEDS OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY
SOUTH BAY. THIS EXPANSION. WILL
ALLOW THE R. M. C. TO SUPPORT
PROJECTS AND PROVIDE GRANTS FOR
CONSERVATION AND CLIMATE
ADAPTATION EFFORTS. THAT THAT
WILL BENEFIT YOU COMMUNITIES FOR
GENERATIONS TO COME WE'VE GOT TO
WITNESSES I'M SORRY I THINK WE
HAVE ONE- WHEN ISN'T AND SUPPORT
THIS ITALIAN GARCIA WITH THE
RIVERS AND MOUNTAINS CONSERVANCY
. VERY GOOD THANK YOU CENTER
ALLEN- SO WE'RE GONNA HAVE THREE
MINUTES THE FOR THIS SUPPORT
TOTAL YOU CAN USE IT IF YOU WISH
OR YOU CAN BE BRIEF REVIEW LIKE-
SALLYANN. PLEASE PROCEED THIS
GARCIA. IF YOU'RE ON A LOT OF
MORNING MORNING MORNING. GOOD
MORNING YES MY NAME SIGNED
CRISTEA I'M A MANAGER OVER AFTER%
THANK YOU A LOWER COST I JUST
RIVER CONSERVANCY. WE BELIEVE
THAT OUR ELEMENTARY DIFFICULT TO
PROVIDE NEIGHBORING AND NEARBY
COMMUNITIES LOCAL SERVICE YOU
CURRENT TERRITORY TOP OF THE
OPPORTUNITY AFTER. THE RESOURCES
CONSISTENT WITH OF MISSION WHAT
PRESERVATION OF OPEN SPACE AND
HABITAT PROTECTION TO PROVIDE
FOR LOW IMPACT RECREATION AND
EDUCATIONAL USES WILDLIFE
HABITAT RESTORATION PROTECTION.
AND WATERSHED IMPROVEMENT. WE
BELIEVE IS HOPED TO X. OUR REACH
A SERVING OF A VITAL IN THE
PLAN. ACQUISITIONS PROJECT
CONSISTENT WITH THE STATE'S OPEN
SPACE AND HABITAT PROTECTION
GOAL OF BOTH WITHIN THE REGION
IN BERKELEY THAT THAT
COMMUNITIES OF NEED. THROUGH A
HOLISTIC APPROACH TO NATURAL
RESOURCE THAT HAS SPENT WITH THE
WATERSHED THE FILLER NEEDS WITH
THE L. A. RIVER WATER BASE THAT
. ASSEMBLY SUBSEQUENTLY
PROFESSION- EXPAND OPPORTUNITIES
PROJECT AND HOW TO PRESERVE THE
NATURAL ENVIRONMENT. OF THE
BEAGLE CHANNEL WATERSHED CYNICAL
CATALINA ISLAND. THE EXPRESSION
INCLUDES AREAS OF HIGH TO VERY
HIGH PARK THE SUCH AS THE CITY
OF INGLEWOOD HAWTHORNE. WHICH
FOLLOW FALL BELOW THE L. A.
COUNTY AVERAGE OF THREE POINT
THREE PARK WHERE IT GROWS PER
ONE THOUSAND PEOPLE. IN IRELAND
NEED FOR PRESERVATION AND
STABILIZATION. OF OPEN SPACE A
LOT OF RESOURCES. WE BELIEVE THE
RTC ANTHONY PUBLIC AND TO HOW
ADDRESS THE ACCORD PROBLEM DUE
TO ITS SIMILARITY. TO THE BEST
COMEDIANS AND OF UNDERSTANDING
OF HOW TO MAXIMIZE RESOURCES
GIVEN FISCAL RESTRAINT.
ADDITIONALLY OUR CURRENT AREA
SHARE GEOGRAPHICALLY POLITICALLY
GOOD FIREMEN. SHARE WITH THE
EXPANDED AREA. WOULD BE ABLE TO
EXPAND OUR COLLABORATION EFFORTS
WITH OTHER GOVERNMENTAL AND NON
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATIONS. TO
SUCCESSFULLY FULFILL OUR
STATUTORY MANDATE UNDER THEIR
RESPECTIVE PROPOSITIONS WHICH
ARE MEANT TO WHICH ALL
CALIFORNIANS. I WANTED A NOTE
BACK ON FEDERAL ADMIN- COMMENT
REGARDING GENTRIFICATION THANK
GOODNESS THERE WAS A PLAN
REGARDING THIS SO WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING ON OUR COMMON GROUND
WHICH WAS US THAT. DURING OUR
ADOPTION OF THE CONSERVANCY AND
WE HAVE BEEN WORKING ON IT AND-
GOING TO BE PROVIDED AT THE
FINAL REPORT NOW THIS DOCUMENT
BUILT ON OVER CENTURY WORK AND
SEEKS TO ENCOURAGE BROAD
PARTICIPATION AND WATERSHED
PLANNING. THE COMPANY PLAN ARE
INTENDED TO SUPPORT IN THE FORM
ON GOING EFFORTS. AT PROVIDING A
FRAMEWORK TO PROVIDE FUTURE
PROJECTS ARE CONSISTENT WITH THE
REGIONAL VISION TO RESTORE
BALANCE. BETWEEN HUMAN AND
NATURAL RESOURCES IN A WATERSHED
. AND ALSO PART OF OUR LOWER L.
A. RIVER REVITALIZATION PLAN WE
HAVE A COMMUNITIES THAT LIVE
NATION TOOL KIT. AND THE PUBLIC
POLICIES AND PROGRAMS THAT WORK.
TO PREVENT DISPLACEMENT OF
JUSTIFICATION BEEN PRETTY
COMMUNITY RELATIONS CLUB-
INSURING FINANCIAL TRANSPARENCY
DURING PROJECT IMPLEMENTATION.
AND MAINTAINING A COMMUNITY
GENERATE INVESTMENT A COMMUNITY.
SO DO YOU. HAVE BEEN. DO YOU
HAVE BEEN UNDER MINE OF COURSE
AND WE ARE WORKING ON IT. AND-
BUT DEFINITELY WILL HAVE A
GREATER. FOCUS ON THAT THE
SPECIAL PREDICAMENT SENATOR.
THANK YOU JUST WRAP UP YOUR YOUR
TESTIMONY HERE WE'RE REMINDED
MARKETS OKAY APPRECIATE BEING
RESPONSIVE CAN YOU JUST WRAP UP
IN THE NEXT FEW. ANSWER HELLO MY
VERY LAST SENTENCE IS THAT WE
THANK YOU US AND OUR FOR
INTERESTING AREN'T SEEK TO
CONTINUE OUR MISSION AND YOUR
DEATH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY- WILL NOW MOVE TO
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT- ANY
IN THE HEARING ROOM. SEEING NONE
MODERATE RETURN TO THE PHONE
LINES TO SEE- IF WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES WISHING TESTIFIED IN
SUPPORT WITH NAME. POSITION AND
AFFILIATION ONLY ON SB ONE ONE
TWO TWO. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT. YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. ONE MOMENT WHILE
WE'RE TOGETHER THE LINE NUMBERS
THANK. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF A FIFTY
ONE ONE TWO TWO YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ENTER AFTER. NINE THIRTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WHAT YOU'RE MEMBERS OF
THE HOUSTON AND REPRESENTING THE
WATERSHED CONSERVATION
AUTHORITY- JURISDICTION JTA
COMPRISED OF THE RIVERS AND
MOUNTAINS CONSERVANCY IN THE L.
A. COUNTY FLOOD CONTROL AGENCY
AND WE'RE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU. AND THE
OTHERS IN SUPPORT. NINE THIRTY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE MORNING MEMBERS JUST
MALIGN HERE ON POCKET HEAL THE
BAY. AND WE AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU. SENATOR ALAN. VERY GOOD
THANK YOU AND THE OTHERS IN
SUPPORT. NINE TWENTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING SENATORS LOOKS
BURKE FROM HALF THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
S. B. ELEVEN TWENTY TWO THANK
YOU OTHERS. FINAL COMMENT IN
SUPPORT IS MINE THIRTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE PAUL
GONZALEZ BEHALF F THE CITY A
COLLECTION IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
MODERATE WE HAVE NO OTHERS IN
SUPPORT ON THE LINE THAT IS
CORRECT OKAY VERY GOOD WILL MOVE
TO ANY- WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
I DON'T SEE ANY IN THE HEARING
ROOM AND WE DON'T HAVE ANY
LISTED. IN THE ANALYSIS- BUT WE
CAN TURN TO THE LINES. I READ IT
WOULD YOU MIND QUEUING UP ANYONE
WISHING TESTIFIED OPPOSITION S.
B. ELEVEN TWENTY TWO. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT
IN OPPOSITION OF SB ELEVEN
THIRTY TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE.
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. BUT
YOU CAN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IS
. OPPOSITION OF SB ELEVEN TWENTY
NINE ERROR ON THE LEFT. YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THE
FRONT. I JUST REPEAT THAT SB
ELEVEN TWENTY TWO IN OPPOSITION
. ALL WE HAVE NO OPPOSITION
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME OKAY
ELEVEN TWENTY TWO VERY GOOD
THANK YOU MA'AM MODERATOR- WILL
TURN BACK TO DIS THEN FOR
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS A CENTER
LAYERED WE HAD A SIMILAR BILL IN
FRONT OF US LAST YEAR IT AND I
HAD A QUESTION ABOUT THE
NONPROFIT SANTA CATALINA
CONSERVANCY AND IT IS ANSWERED
IN THE- ANALYSIS THIS YEAR SO IT
DOES SOUND LIKE THERE'S WORK TO
COORDINATE SO. I WOULD HAPPILY
MOVED THIS BILL. VERY GOOD IT'S
EMOTIONAL CENTER LAYERED ANY
OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS-
SEEING NONE- THERE L. WOULD LIKE
TO CLOSE YEAH I THINK YOU THINK
YOU MEMBERS THANK YOU TO THE
FOLKS WHO TESTIFIED IN SUPPORT I
DO ONE OF I DO WANT TO POINT
OUT- THIS LITTLE PARAGRAPH AT
THE BOTTOM OF PAGE FOUR OF YOUR
ANALYSIS BECAUSE I DO THINK IT
POINTS OUT WHY IT'S AND WHY WHY
WE RUN THESE KINDS OF BILLS. ON
CATALINA ISLAND IT'S A BEAUTIFUL
PLACES YOU KNOW NEARLY ALL THE
ISLAND IS OWNED BY THE
CALIFORNIA IS OUR BY THE
CATALINA ISLAND CONSERVANCY
WHICH DOES OP OPERATE AS A
PRIVATE NONPROFIT CONSERVANCY
PROTECTING THE ISLAND FROM
DEVELOPMENT WITH A FOCUS ON
CONSERVATION AND RESTORATION
RECREATION. BUT THEY THEY'VE
COME TO A PLACE WHERE THEY
STRUGGLE TO FIND TO GET FUNDING
TO HELP SUPPORT THEIR EFFORTS.
HI AND THEY WOULD HAVE MORE
SUCCESS IN PARTNERING WITH THE
CONSERVANCY LIKE THE RMC OFFER
CRITICAL PROJECTS ON THE ISLAND
THAT THAT WILL REALLY BENEFIT
ALL THE MANY MANY PEOPLE MILLION
ANNUAL VISITORS TO THE ISLAND-
SO IT'S ONE OF THE MANY MANY
REASONS WHY A BILL LIKE THIS IS
IMPORTANT. AND IT'S BEEN DONE IN
FULL COOPERATION WITH THE FOLKS
ON THE ISLAND OF COURSE ALL THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE GOING TO BE
INCLUDED IN THIS TERRITORY AS IT
EXPANDS. SO WITH THAT VERY MUCH
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING CLOSELY
WITH ENTERCOM LAGER AND THE
FOLKS FROM THE BALDWIN HILLS
CONSERVANCY OTHER MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE AS WE ADDRESS
THAT LITTLE OVERLAP ISSUE AS AS
AS MENTIONED- AND- RESPECT
RATIONALE VOTE. VERY GOOD- THE
MOTIONS. CENTER LAYERED BELIEVE
IT IS TO PASS BUT FIRST. A RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. ME DOUBLE CHECK
THAT. THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT THE
MOST. SO CHIEF CONSULTANT THAT'D
BE THE MOTION THIS CALL THE ROLL
FILE ITEM EIGHT S. B. ONE ONE
TWO TWO MOTIONS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS STERN. HI STERN
ALL RIGHT JONES JONES AYE ALLEN
. ALLEN ALL RIGHT EGGMAN EGGMAN
AYE GROVE HERTZBERG HERTZBERG
ALL RIGHT HUESO HUESO ARE A
LAYERED HI LAYARD ISLA MON LIMÓN
HI. HE OKAY THE MEASURES EIGHT
THE BILLS OUT- WE SHOULD NOTE
ALSO THAT CENTER GROVE IS ABSENT
TODAY SO WE WILL NOT BE LEAVING
THE ROLE OPEN FORHER- AND WILL
TURN I THINK CENTER ALLEN YOU
MIGHT IF WE TURN TO CENTER
LAYERED THE ABSENCE OF A LEAD OR
DO YOU HAVE YOUR YEARLY WITNESS
FOR. FILE ITEM SEVEN HERE. OKAY
YEAH LET'S DO THAT- EARLIER-
WERE UP TO FILE ITEM NINE. AND
JUST FOR THOSE WHO HAVEN'T HEARD
THERE IS A REVISED ANALYSIS OF
THIS ITEM. ITEM NINE S. B. NINE
FORTY FIVE THE ONLY CHANGES TO
THE RECOMMENDED AMENDMENTS WHICH
NOW REFLECTS AN AGREEMENT
BETWEEN THE COMMITTEE STEPHANIE
AUTHOR. SO THE REVISED ANALYSIS
IS WHAT IS ONLINE NOW AND SHOULD
BE IN YOUR BINDERS MEMBERS. WILL
HAVE COPIES OF THE REVISED
AMENDMENT THOSE IN THE ROOM I
WANT TO COPY. PLEASE SEE THE
SERGEANTS IF YOU'D LIKE ONE I'M
SAID EARLIER WITH THAT PLEASE
PROCEED THANK YOU- MISTER CHAIR.
AND THANKS FOR YOUR- YOU AND
YOUR STAFF YOU TIME AND
ATTENTION TO THE SENATE BILL
NINE FORTY FIVE WHICH I'M
PRESENTING. AND I WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS AND WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT'S ON THE RECORD. SENATE
BILL NINE FORTY FIVE ALLOWS A
CALIFORNIA LICENSED FALCONER. TO
CAPTURE POSSESS AND TRAINED
AMERICAN PEREGRINE FALCON IN THE
PRACTICE OF FALCONRY. THE
HUNTING OF WILD ANIMALS IN THEIR
NATURAL STATE AND HABITAT. A BY
A MEANS OF A TRAINED BIRD OF.
PREY THE WORD TAKE HAS BEEN
USED. IN OTHER INSTANCES IT
MIGHT MEAN WE'RE LITERALLY
TAKING THE LIFE OF THE SPECIES
BUT IN THIS CASE. THE TAKE IS TO
POSSESS AND TRAIN. WHICH IS A
VERY IMPORTANT DISTINCTION. AND
PEOPLE MIGHT SAY WHAT'S THE
PURPOSE OF THIS BILL. OF THE
PURPOSE OF THIS BILL. IS TO
ALLOW POSSESSION OF A PEREGRINE
FOR FALCONRY ACCORDING TO THE
LIMIT SET BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE AS IN ELEVEN
OTHER STATES. AND THAT'S BECAUSE
OF. THE REHABILITATION AND
RESCUE BIRDS FOR EXAMPLE. BOB
PEREGRINES NEST ON MOST BRIDGES
IN THE BAY AREA AROUND THE
STATE. SUCH AS THE VINCENT
THOMAS BRIDGE THE BAY BRIDGE TO
SAN RAFAEL BRIDGE. UP AND
OTHERS. YOUNG PEREGRINES ARE
CLUMSY. AND OFTEN FLOODS INTO
THE WATER AND DROWN BECAUSE THEY
MAKE POOR LANDINGS AFTER THEIR
FIRST FLIGHTS. BUT UNDER CURRENT
LAW- NOBODY'S ALLOWED TO SAVE
THEM- OR DO A TAKE THAT IS TO
TAKE FOR ACTUALLY TRAINING AND
POSSESSING. SO UNDER THIS BILL A
LICENSED FALCONER MAY POSSESS AN
AMERICAN PEREGRINE FALCON AND
USE IT IN FALCONRY WORK WHEREAS
CURRENTLY THEY CANNOT. AND JUST
FOR BACKGROUND BEGINNING IN THE
NINETEEN FORTIES DUE TO THE
WIDESPREAD USE OF PESTICIDES
SUCH AS DDT A PRECIPITOUS
DECLINE IN THE POPULATION
HAPPENED. IN THE NINETEEN
SIXTIES FULLY PROTECTED
PROVISIONS OF THE FISH AND GAME
CODE WERE ESTABLISHED AS
CALIFORNIA'S INITIAL EFFORT TO
IDENTIFY. ADDITIONAL PROTECTION
BUT TO FULLY PROTECTED LIST
PROHIBITED POSSESSION AND TAKE
OF THE AMERICAN PEREGRINE FALCON
FOR FEMALE CANARY. AND THE
ENDANGERED SPECIES ACT AS LONG
SINCE REPLACED FISH AND GAME
CODE TO FULLY PROTECTED SO THIS
WILL ALLOW LICENSED FALCONERS
WHO MUCH PASS A WRITTEN TEST. IN
ADDITION TO UNDERGOING A TWO
YEAR APPRENTICESHIP TO AGAIN
USED A PEREGRINE FALCON IN THE
PRACTICE OF FALCONRY. WITH ME TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. IS STEWART A
LICENSE FALCONER WITH THE UC
SANTA CRUZ PREDATORY BIRD
RESEARCH GROUP AND BILL FERRIER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA HAWKING
CLUB- I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
NINE FROM. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
WANNA HEAR FROM OUR LEAD
WITNESSES YOU HAVE THREE MINUTES
TOTAL- PLEASE PROCEED. BUT AGAIN
MY NAME IS GLEN STEWART. I'M
RETIRED DIRECTOR OF THE UC SANTA
CRUZ PREDATORY BIRD RESEARCH
GROUP AND I'VE BEEN A FALCONER
FOR FIFTY YEARS. I'M ASKING YOU
TODAY TO AGAIN GET FAULCONER IS
ACCESS TO THE CLASSIC BIRDSALL
CAN READ THE PEREGRINE FALCONS.
AND I SAY AGAIN BECAUSE WE HAVE
TO USE THEM AND FALCONERI FOR
FOUR THOUSAND YEARS. EXCEPT
DURING THE PAST FIFTY. WHEN
THEY'RE USED TO SUSPENDED WHY
BECAUSE OF DDT AS SENATOR
LAYERED POINTED OUT. IT
DECIMATED THEIR POPULATIONS
WORLDWIDE. CALIFORNIA DID THE
RIGHT THING BY IMPLEMENTING
FULLY PROTECTED THE FISHING GAME
COACH THREE YEARS AGO BUT IS NOW
ANTIQUATED LAW. IT FULLY
PROTECTS BIRDS THAT NO LONGER
NEED PROTECTION WHILE THE
CALIFORNIA ENDANGERED SPECIES
ACT PROTECTS THOSE THE DEAL.
CALIFORNIA TODAY THAN AT ANY
TIME IN HISTORY. I WAS A PART OF
THE TEAM AT UC SANTA CRUZ THAT
HELPED. JOBS BEEN DONE. BEEN
FINISHED FOR TWENTY YEARS.
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
IS DOCUMENTED A ROBUST
POPULATION REMOVED THE PEREGRINE
FROM THE STATE'S ENDANGERED
SPECIES LAPSED. AND DEPARTMENT
RECENTLY UPDATED FALCONRY
REGULATIONS THAT GOVERN THE USE
OF WILD BIRDS AND FALKIRK RIGHT.
IF YOU HAVE A BIRD BOOK. ON YOUR
SHELF IT IS LIKELY THAT ROGER
TORY PETERSON WROTE IT LIKE TO
READ FIRST TWO SENTENCES OF HIS
PEREGRINE FALCON ACCOUNT. ITS
BOOK BIRDS OVER AMERICA SPEAK
SHARPLY. WITH THE BIRD. MANAGED
FROM THE AVENTURE. ORGANON IS
RED IT'S- BROWN I MORE THAN THAT
WAS BEEN OTHER FOR BEEN WITNESS
TO THE STRUGGLE FOR CIVILIZATION
. PLEASE PASS THIS BILL TODAY
AND EXAM ROOMS FROM THE FALCONRY
RESTRICTIONS OF FULLY PROTECTED
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. A MORNING MY NAME IS DR
BILL I AM A RETIRED UC DAVIS
VETERINARIAN AND THE RETIRED
DIRECTOR OF THE UC DAVIS RAPTOR
CENTER A CENTER THAT IS DEVOTED
TO PROVIDING MEDICAL TREATMENT
TO INJURED WILD RAPTORS AND
RELEASING THEM BACK INTO THE
WILD I HAVE ALSO BEEN A
FAULCONER FOR OVER FIFTY YEARS
FALCONRY IS CONSIDERED AN
INTANGIBLE CULTURAL HERITAGE BY
UNESCO. PART OF THAT HERITAGE IS
BEING ABLE TO TRAP WILD
PEREGRINES FOR USE IN FALCONRY
CURRENTLY CALIFORNIA THE HIGHEST
BREEDING POPULATION OF
PEREGRINES IN THE COUNTRY YEAH
WE DO NOT HAVE ACCESS TO THIS
RESOURCE I HAVE TRAVELED TO
TEXAS AND WASHINGTON STATE WITH
NON RESIDENT PERMITS TO TRAP
PEREGRINES TRAPPING PEREGRINES
IS COSTLY AND DIFFICULT I AM THE
ONLY OUT OF STATE FAULCONER TO
HAVE SUCCESSFULLY TRAPPED THE
PEREGRINE IN WASHINGTON. AS I
MADE THE TWO THOUSAND MILE ONE
KEPT ASKING MYSELF IS WHY DO I
HAVE TO DRIVE TO TEXAS WHEN THE
PEREGRINES PLENTIFUL CALIFORNIA
ADDITIONALLY THE MORTALITY OF
THESE FIRST YEAR BIRDS OVER 50%
FAULCONER HUSING WHILE TRY
PEREGRINES ACTUALLY HELP THE
BIRDS GET THROUGH THEIR FIRST
YEAR. I AM ASKING THAT THE
OWNERS ARE AGAIN GIVEN HOW TO
THE PEREGRINE FALCON IN
CALIFORNIA THE IMMENSE POPULAR
BY A- DATA SUPPORT THIS
DECISION. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU- WILL
NOW TURN TO THE GENERAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ANY IN THE
HEARING ROOM WISHING TESTIFY.
PLEASE COME FORWARD SEEN NONE.
MODERATOR WILL TURN TO THE LINES
ANYONE WISHING TESTIFIED AS
GENERAL SUPPORT WITNESS NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
BILL. PLEASE TURN TO THE LINES.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH
TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE
FORTY FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF SB. NINE FORTY FIVE.
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN- ONE
MOMENT WHILE WE GATHER THE
NUMBERS.
NINE TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS BILL GAINES SPEAKING
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
WATERFOWL ASSOCIATION THE
CALIFORNIA BOWMAN UNDERSTATE
ARCHERY ASSOCIATION THE BLACK
BRANT GROUP THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING FOR CONSERVATION THE SAN
DIEGO COUNTY WILDLIFE BETTER.
THE BASE WEAPON ASSOCIATE AND
THE SAN OF SCOPE AREA TO OF
SPARGO INTERNATIONAL IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL NINE
FORTY FIVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
OTHERS IN SUPPORT. NINE TWENTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
HEALING HAWKINS BUT THE
CONGRESSIONAL WORKMEN FOUNDATION
HERE TODAY AND SUPPORT THANK YOU
OTHERS IN SUPPORT. WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF SB
NINE FORTY FIVE OKAY VERY GOOD-
NOW WE'LL TURN TO OF FITNESS IS
IN OPPOSITION AND IN THE HEARING
ROOM. SEEING NINE MODERATOR
WE'LL TURN TO THE LINES ANYONE
WITH DISH WHICH WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB NINE
FORTY FIVE PLEASE QUEUE THEM UP
. THANK YOU MISTER TURNER AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH
TO COMMENT IN OPPOSITION OF SB
NINE FORTY FIVE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN. YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION OF SB NINE FORTY
FIVE. YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. WE HAVE NO COMMENTS IN THE
QUEUE AT THIS TIME IN OPPOSITION
OF SB NINE FORTY FIVE. OKAY
WE'LL TAKE THAT AS OF THE END OF
OPPOSITION TESTIMONY BRING IT
BACK TO THE DICE MEMBERS YOU
HAVE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ON SB
NINE FORTY FIVE- MOTION FROM
SENATOR HERTZBERG- I DO HAVE A
FEW QUESTIONS FOR THE AUTHOR- I
KNOW WE'VE WE WORK THROUGH SOME
OF THESE ISSUES IN THE REPORTING
BUT I JUST WENT ON THE RECORD
JUST TO GET. YOUR SENSE OF-
BECAUSE I APPLIED THE SAME SORT
OF STANDARD IN QUESTION TO.
OTHER BILLS MOVING THROUGH THIS
COMMITTEE THAT MAY HAVE- AN
IMPACT ON THE SERVER BASED
BUDGETING OCCURRING AT THE
DEPARTMENT- HOPING FOR YOUR YOUR
FEEDBACK THERE ARE KNOW THAT
IT'S- AN ISSUE THAT WILL
HOPEFULLY BE WORKED ON- IN
FISCAL COMMITTEE BUT- FOR THE
BECAUSE OF THE LACK OF DATA
RIGHT NOW IN THE LACK OF A- I
MANAGED. PLAN I THINK WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY'VE GOT ALL
THE TOOLS THEY NEED TO MAKE SURE
THE- OVERALL SPECIES REMAINS
INTACT- WITH HIS PRACTICE IN
PLACE JUST GIVEN THE LACK OF
DATA UST HOPING YOU COULD-
PROVIDE SOME ASSURANCE OR
COMMENTARY FOR THE RECORD. WELL
LET ME PROVIDE SOME COMMENTARY
WHICH IS THERE SOME THINGS THAT
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE WOULD BE DOING
REGARDLESS OF THIS BILL. IN I
THINK SOMEHOW THEY GET SWEPT
INTO THIS AS WELL SO I THINK THE
COSTS AS A RESULT OF THIS BILL
ARE MINIMAL. BUT AT THE SAME
TIME- THAT THEY HAVE PLANS THAT
THEY HAVE TO DO REGARDLESS
BENDIS WILL NOW BE INCLUDED IN
SOME WAYS IN THE PLANS THAT THEY
HAVE TO DO REGARDLESS AND- I'M A
MEMBER OF THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE WILL MAKE SURE THIS IS
FULLY VETTED AND THAT. THANK YOU
FOR THAT AND I AND I ALSO WANT
TO JUST THANK YOU FOR THE
AMENDMENTS AND JUST TO BE CLEAR
THE ANALYSIS DOES NOTE IT'S NOT
KNOWN WHAT IMPACT. THIS
AUTHORIZATION WOULD HAVE BUT- WE
HOPE THIS LEGISLATIVE REPORTING
CRIME IS A LONG WAYS TO THAT SO
WE APPRECIATE YOU WORKING WITH
US. WE HAVE A MOTION FROM
SENATOR HERTZBERG- IF YOU'D LIKE
TO CLOSE I WOULD JUST THANK THE
WITNESSES. IN SUPPORT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
PHONE. OKAY CHIEF CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL I'D LEAVE
THE- MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED- AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
FILE ITEM NINE S. B. FOUR FIVE
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS STERN HI STERN
ALL RIGHT. JONES HI ALAN. ALLEN
AYE EGGMAN. EGGMAN ALL RIGHT
GROVE- HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG ALL
RIGHT HUESO. WE ON A LAYER AYE
LAYERED AYE LIMÓN. MON ALL RIGHT
. THE MEASURES EIGHT- THE BILLS
OUT- WE WILL MOVE ON. TO ROUND
WOULD YOU LIKE PROCEED ON ABOUT-
FILE ITEM. ESPYS TEN SEVENTY
EIGHT MEMBERS. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER CHAIR SO S. AS SOME OF
YOU MAY KNOW LAST YEAR I
INTRODUCED A BILL THAT WAS
SIMILAR TO THIS ONE- WHICH
PASSED THE LEGISLATURE WITH
BROAD BROAD BI. SUPPORT THE WE
SEEM TO- THE GOAL. IS TO
ESTABLISH A SEA LEVEL RISE
REVOLVING LOAN FUND TO PROVIDE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WITH AN
INNOVATIVE FINANCING OPTION TO
ALLEVIATE THE RISKS. OF SEA
LEVEL RISE WHILE PROTECTING BOTH
PROPERTY OWNERS AND TAXPAYERS-
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT HAS
BECOME A MAJOR PROBLEM FOR A LOT
OF LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND THE L.
A. TIMES THAT A FASCINATING
PIECE ON THIS. I THAT I COMMEND
EVERYONE IT'S BEEN A REALLY
HIGHLIGHTED THAT THE UNIQUE
CHALLENGES AND AN EXCRUCIATING
CHALLENGES THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
ARE FACING THE HAVE A GROUP OF.
HOMEOWNERS WHO LIVE RIGHT ON THE
COAST WHO ARE COMING IN ASKING
THEM TO SPEND MORE AND MORE OF
THEIR MEAGER CITY BUDGETS ON.
FIGHTING BACK AGAINST SEA LEVEL
RISE WHILE THERE YOU KNOW
WHETHER THEY'RE NOT ABLE TO FIND
OTHER. NEEDS FROM YOU KNOW PARKS
AND SENIOR PROGRAMS-
TRANSPORTATION LAW ENFORCEMENT
WHATEVER ELSE. SO THE IDEA HERE
IS THAT WE WOULD CREATE A OF AN
ABSOLUTE VOLUNTARY. LOAN FUND
THAT WOULD CANCEL OUT IT WOULD
BREAK EVEN- YOU WOULD PROVIDE
THIS FINANCING TOOL OVER THE
WOULD LOAN MONEY TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THAT COULD THEN BUY
PROPERTIES THAT WILL BE
THREATENED BY SEA LEVEL RISE. IN
A DECADE OR TWO ENABLING THE
OWNERS TO SELL WHILE THE
PROPERTY STILL HAVE VALUE AND
THEN THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT COULD
AND RAN OUT THE PROPERTY.
REPAYING THE LOAN A POTENTIALLY
EVEN EARNING REVENUE. I WHEN THE
PROPERTY IS NO LONGER
INHABITABLE DUE TO THE RISK OF
FLOODING FROM RISING SEA LEVELS
THE HOUSE COULD BE DEMOLISHED OR
RELOCATED WITHOUT. THE LOCAL
RESIDENTS OR TAXPAYERS BEARING
THE COST. SO ON THE GOVERNOR
VETOED THE BILL LAST YEAR WE
READ HIS VETO STATEMENT TALK TO
POKE THE MINISTRATION VERY
CAREFULLY AND WE'VE ADJUSTED OUR
PROPOSAL. IN CLOSE COOPERATION
WITH THE STATE COMPTROLLER WHO
WILL BE TESTIFYING SHORTLY AND
WE WOULD JUST OF THE PROPOSED IN
TWO KEY WAYS THAT WE THINK WILL
ADDRESS THE GOVERNOR'S CONCERNS
FIRST OF ALL THE BILL
PRIORITIZES. FUNDING FIRST A LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES IN THOSE
HARDEST HIT BY CLIMATE CHANGE
THE BILL ALSO CALLS FOR
PARTICIPATING LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO CRAFT. PROJECT- THE PROPERTY
VULNERABILITY ASSESSMENTS. AND
TO INCORPORATE THESE ASSESSMENTS
INTO THEIR CURRENT. LOCAL
COASTAL PLAN. HI THIS WILL BE
ENSURE THAT THE NEW PROGRAM IS
WELL INTEGRATED INTO EXISTING
EFFORTS TO ADDRESS YOU AUTHORIZE
COURTNEY WITH THE PRO TIMES SB
ONE THAT WE PASSED LAST YEAR. I
SAW IT AS A MENTION LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE ARE THEIR
THEY'RE STRUGGLING TO FIND
CREATIVE WAYS TO ADDRESS THE
CLIMATE CRISIS WHILE BALANCING.
VERY LIMITED BUDGETS. THEY'RE
NOT MANY OPTIONS AND ALSO
ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF LOCAL
RESIDENTS PROPERTY OWNERS- YEAH
THIS IS BEEN A REAL ISSUE OF
CONTROVERSY A LOT OF COMMUNITIES
IN THE COURSE BUILDING SEA WALLS
WHICH OF COURSE IS THE- THE
PREFERRED- MITIGATION IS THIS
NOT JUST EXPENSIVE BUT- AS YOUR
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS POINTS OUT IT
COMES WITH A- SERIOUS
ENVIRONMENTAL CONSEQUENCES FIRST
OF ALL. YOU CAN NEVER WIN
AGAINST THE C. IN THE LONG RUN
BUT IT ALSO IMPACTS. THE FLOW OF
SAND AND THAT HAS IMPACTS ON ON
YOUR WHEN ONE COMMITTEE BILL TO
SEE WALL IT NEGATIVELY IMPACTS
OTHER COASTAL COMMUNITIES UP AND
DOWN THE COAST. I BECAUSE IT
KIND OF PUSHES OFF THE PROBLEM
ON TO THEM. TO ALL THE CHOICES
WE NEED TO MAKE ARE TOUGH-
THEY'LL GET A WHOLE LOT HARDER
WHEN INSURANCE COMPANIES REFUSE
TO COVER PROPERTIES AND BANKS
WILL PROVIDE MORTGAGES AND THEN
WERE ASKED TO STEP IN AND TRY TO
HELP. HELP OUT I JUST THINK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE LIVES AND
TREASURE THAT COULD HAVE BEEN
SAVED IF- WE TAKEN PROACTIVE
ACTION TWO DECADES AGO HOW TO
PREVENT. OR TO LEAST OF REDUCE
THE POSSIBILITY OF THESE
DEVASTATING WILDFIRES THAT WE
NOW HAVE. SO WITH ME HERE TO
SPEAK TODAY I JUST WANT TO THANK
OUR TO OUR OUR STATE'S CHIEF
FISCAL OFFICER STATE CONTROLLER
BETTY YEE- FOR HER SUPPORT AND
HER ENGAGEMENT. DEEP ENGAGEMENT
ON THIS BILL AS WELL AS ISABEL
GONZALEZ POTTER REPRESENTING.
THE NATURE CONSERVANCY. VERY
VERY- WILL TURN TO THE LEAD
WITNESSES THEN- AND STATE
CONTROLLER YOU ON THE LINE WITH
US. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
CHRISTINA CONGLETON THE
CONTROLLER DEPUTY FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL POLICY CONTROL HE
CENTRAL POLICIES HE SHE'S GOT
ANOTHER CALL. I WOULD HAVE TO
BUY TODAY ON HER BEHALF OKAY
PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY TODAY ON AT TEN SEVENTY
EIGHT AND IMPORTANT BILL THE
CONTROLLER IS PLEASED TO
SPONSOR. AND SEVENTY EIGHT IN
THE BILL THAT WHILE PROACTIVELY
ADDRESSED THE EXPONENTIAL THREAT
AT THE LEVEL RIDE. WE OFTEN
THINK OF LEVEL RISES BEING
BARRED. BUT EXTREME AND NUISANCE
IN BLOCKED THE ARE ALREADY FOR
HOME AND CAL. COPPING CHARACTER
FIND INVITE IMPACTS. A
CALIFORNIA CHIEF FISCAL.
CONTROLLER HE REALIZES THAT THE
RISKIEST RESPONSE TO SEALEVEL
RISE IS IN ACTION. WITHIN THE
NEXT THREE DECADES THE LEVEL
RIDE THE FORECAST TO COST MORE
THAN SEVENTEEN BILLION DOLLARS
IN PROPERTY DAMAGE ON
CALIFORNIA'S COASTLINE.
EXACERBATING EXISTING
SOCIOECONOMIC INEQUITIES.
PARTICULARLY FOR INDIGENOUS AND
LOW INCOME PEOPLE OF COLOR. WHEN
POSSIBLE AND PRACTICAL THE MOST
EFFECTIVE WAY TO AVOID THE
IMPACT OF SEA LEVEL RISE. IT'S A
NEW PEOPLE AND PROPERTIES AWAY
FROM RISING SEAS. HOWEVER
ADAPTATION STRATEGIES TO BE
DESIGNED TO MEET THE NEEDS FOR
EACH OF CALIFORNIANS. COMMUNITY
I THE TIME THAT WE GET A COMP
THAT FILE LOW JR. TO DETERMINE
IF THAT PROGRAM IS BEAUTIFUL FOR
THEIR UNIQUE NEEDS. ALL ALLOWING
ON TO BUY. PART BUT THE PROBES
PROVIDE OPPORTUNE TO TAKE A PRO
. AND TO CONSIDER PEOPLE BEFORE
TO A STATEWIDE. DOING FELL WILL
ALIGN WITH THE L. A. O. TWENTY
RECOMMENDED FACT ON SEALABLE
RIGHT PREPARATIONS NOW. TO AVOID
LOST OPPORTUNITY AND HIGH COSTS
. AND DIRTIER FACE OUT OF ACT.
WHAT MONTH IDC FEAR REITERATED
THAT JUST AND EQUITY HOW THINK
AND ON HOW THE FACT AT CAN BE.
AT SEVENTY ENSURE THE
COMMUNITIES WITH THE GREATEST
NEED FOR SUPPORT FIRST BEFORE HE
LEVEL RIGHTS RELATED FLOODING
IMPACTS VALUE OF THEIR HOME. IN
THE U. S. MOST BY OUT POLICIES
ARE REACTIONARY. TO NATURAL
DISASTERS REQUIRE RESIDENTS TO
IMMEDIATELY ABANDON THE PROPERTY
IMPACTING RENTERS AND ADDING
STRESS TO REGIONAL HOUSING
NEEDS. AT THE TEN SEVENTY EIGHT
A VOICE BY FOR THE STATE WITH AN
INVALUABLE. TO PLANET. WITHIN A
PRE DEVELOPED CONTACT AND ALLOW
RESIDENTS REMAIN IN THEIR HOME
UNTIL IT NO LONGER HABITABLE.
COUNTING TIME PER. WITH A
CRITICAL NEED FOR HELPING. AT
THE TIME THAT EIGHT IS A GROUND
. ADAPTATION PHYLLIS. ALIGNED
WITH A WIDE VIEW OF RIGHT POLICY
AND THE FACT OF SCIENCE WE HAVE
A SHORT WINDOW OF OPPORTUNITY TO
INVEST IN INNOVATIVE DEAL ALL
RIGHT POLICY. WE CANNOT TO WAIT
TO ACT BUT THE SLOW MOVING AND
PREDICTABLE. OF SEA LEVEL RISE
CREATE OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO GET
AHEAD OF THE CURVE TODAY. I'D BE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH-
WILL NOW TURN TO OUR SECOND LEAD
WITNESS MISS POTTER. HI CAN YOU
HEAR ME OK YES WE GOT YOU YOU'RE
COMING THROUGH. OKAY THANK YOU
AND GOOD MORNING MISTER TURNER
MEMBERS MY NAME IS SULLIVAN
PALETTE FATHER OF A POLICY
ASSOCIATE WITH ANY CONSERVANCY.
MANAGER CONSERVANCY STRONGLY
SUPPORTS SB TEN SEVENTY EIGHT
CORRECT. THE INCREDIBLE COMMON
PARTY MADE BIKE COOLEY STAFF AND
AN INTEREST IN NOT BE REDUNDANT
I'LL KEEP MY COMMON ARE IN SAY
THAT. WITH THE PACIFIC PROJECTED
TO RISE NOW FEET IN SOME COASTAL
AREAS OF CALIFORNIA BY TWENTY
ONE. WE NEED TO DO ACTION TO
PROTECT THE ENTIRE COAST WE LOVE
IT DEPEND ON WHETHER DEVELOPED
OR WILD. BECAUSE THE FINANCIAL
THAT IF WE CONTINUE TO THINK OUR
HEADS IN THE SAND WILL BE UNDER
WATER THANK YOU VERY MUCH. VERY
BROUGH AN VERY POINTED- THANK
YOU SO MUCH MISS POTTER I KNOW
WILL. WILL THE CHEN WITNESSES IN
SOME. I DO EVEN IN HERE ROOM-
SEEING NINE MODERATOR LET'S TURN
THE LINES AND- SEE GENERAL
SUPPORT FOR SB TEN SEVENTY EIGHT
HERE. NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ON THE BILL. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT
IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVENTY EIGHT
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO COME INTO COURT AND THE
TEN SEVENTY EIGHT. IN A PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. ONE SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS ERIN WILLIAMS ON
BEHALF OF JERICHO CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT OF SB TEN SEVENTY EIGHT
THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT. AND ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. NINE THIRTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO ANY GOVERNMENTAL ON
THE FRONT OF CALIFORNIANS PARKS
FOUNDATION AND STRONG SUPPORTER
OF SB TEN SEVENTY EIGHT THANK
YOU VERY GOOD THANKS SO MUCH
NEXT. WE HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT
IN SUPPORT OF SB TEN SEVENTY
EIGHT. OKAY WILL TURN INTO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION ANYONE
IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM WISHING
TESTIFIED OPPOSITION SEEING
NONE- ANYONE ON THE LINE
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE KEEP
ANYONE WISHING TESTIFIED. IN
OPPOSITION TO SB. TEN SEVENTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN OPPOSITION OF
SB TEN SEVENTY EIGHT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN A POSITION OF SB TEN
SEVENTY EIGHT. YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN THERE. WE HAVE NO
OPPOSITION COMMON. U. S. B. TEND
. OKAY VERY GOOD WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE DIES THEN MEMBERS
COMMENTS QUESTIONS- CENTER
LAYERED THANK YOU- MISTER CARE.
D. A. I THINK THAT THE AUTHOR
AND THE WITNESSES BUT MADE A
VERY GOOD CASE. IN AND WITH
REGARD TO MISS POTTER I THINK
SHE WAS ACTUALLY MARC WITH
POLITE BECAUSE WHEN I WAS
RESOURCES SECRETARY. I WOULD SAY
GRAPHICALLY IF YOU STICK YOUR
HEAD IN THE SAND YOU WILL DROWN
. I DIDN'T BEAT AROUND THE BUSH.
IN THE AUTHOR MADE A COMMENT
ABOUT IF WE HAD DONE A BILL
FIFTEEN OR TWENTY YEARS AGO AND
- I DID FIRST ONE. IT ANY WAS TO
REQUIRED GENERAL PLANS. OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ALONG THE COAST TO
TAKE INTO ACCOUNT SEA LEVEL RISE
AND I. RAN INTO THIS CONFLICT IN
OF ALL PLACES THE STATE SENATE-
WHICH WAS HALF THE STAKEHOLDERS
SAID. WE WON'T SUPPORT THIS BILL
AND UNLESS YOU HAVE A SPECIFIC
BASELINE FOR PLANNING AND THE
OTHER HALF SAID WE WON'T SUPPORT
THIS BILL IF YOU DO HAVE A
SPECIFIC BASELINE FOR PLANNING.
AND I COULDN'T GET IT OUT OF THE
SENATE. AND OF THE WORLD HAS
CHANGED SINCE THEN. IN THE IN
THE SENSE THAT. THIS IS UPON US
AND PEOPLE IN THE FUTURE GOING
TO ASK WHY WE DIDN'T TAKE EVEN
STRONGER STEPS. AND THIS IS
ANOTHER ONE OF THOSE PLACES
WHERE WE HAVE TO HAVE AN ALL OF
THE ABOVE STRATEGY WE HAVE TO DO
THIS ANY OF A NUMBER OF WAYS
BECAUSE IT'S GOING TO BE AN
OVERWHELMING PROBLEM. ARE ARE ON
THE COAST AND ARE BASED IN SO- I
APPRECIATE THE ATTEMPT TO THE
OFFICER TO WORK WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE ON THE VETO I
THINK HE- HAS THE AUTHOR HAS
ADDRESSED. FROM MANY OF THE
ISSUES AND I THINK IT IS
IMPORTANT TO MOVE THIS BILL HAD
STRONGLY SO WE SEND THE SIGNAL
THAT WE SUPPORT THE ALL OF THE
ABOVE AND FORCE THE
NEGOTIATIONS. THAT SHOULD HAPPEN
IF THEY HAVEN'T- IF THIS BILL
DOESN'T ALREADY TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT THOSE BECAUSE WE NEED TO
DO MANY DIFFERENT SITES WITH THE
AUTHOR. I LOOK FORWARD TO
SUPPORTING THIS AND I WOULD
ACTUALLY MOVE THE BILL THERE IT
IS THERE'S A MOTIONS THAT ARE
LAYERED- CENTER JONES. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND- SIR ALAN. I
SAW. LAST YEAR BILL- BECAUSE I
AGREED WITH YOU THOSE INNOVATIVE
AND I AND I THOUGHT WE WERE
MOVING IN THE RIGHT RIGHT
DIRECTION THE SO THE QUESTION
FOR THIS BILL IS I DON'T
UNDERSTAND AFTER READING THE-
GOVERNOR'S VETO MESSAGE. HOW
THIS BILL ADDRESSES THE CONCERNS
THAT THE GOVERNOR RAISED AND-
REGARDING- FUNDING AND THEN- YOU
KNOW GENERAL PLANNING PROCESS
FOR THE ENTIRE STATE IT SEEMS
LIKE TO ME THAT THIS BILL
ACTUALLY NARROWS. THE. IMPACT OF
THE BILL WHEN YOU'RE WHEN YOU'RE
- TAKING DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES
FOR DIFFERENT REASONS RATHER
THAN BASED ON RISK- SO JUST
WONDERING IF YOUCOULD KIND OF
SPEAK TO THE GOVERNOR'S VETO AND
HOW THIS ADDRESSES IT. WELL I
MEAN IT DOES WE DO WE DO- PUT
FOCUS ON ON RISK AS WELL BECAUSE
WE HAD AND- THOSE PARTICIPATE
CLIMATE CHANGE WHICH WOULD YOU
KNOW INCLUDE THOSE FOLKS WHO
ARE- LIKELY TO HAVE THEIR
PROPERTIES INVOLVED BY THE BY
THE SEA. I'M YOUR IS THIS YOUR
MESSAGE WAS. SOMEWHAT CRYPTIC-
WE- YOU KNOW IT DID IT DID
MENTION SEVERAL TIMES A
COMPREHENSIVE LANDS AND WORKING
COMPREHENSIVELY AND- YOU KNOW WE
WHAT ONE OF ONE OF THE MANY
THINGS THAT WE READ INTO THIS
WAS THAT MAYBE WE NEED TO. MAKE
SURE THAT WE GET THE
PARTICIPATING LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO REALLY GET SOME SKIN IN THE
GAME AND SURE THAT THEIR
PROPERTY ONE OF THE LEAST
ESTIMATES ARE ARE. PERFORATED
INTO THEIR CURRENT LOCAL COASTAL
PLANS- YOU KNOW WE'RE WE'RE OFF
THE GOOD EVENING WE'VE BEEN TO
THE PRESS TIMES OFFICE AND SHE
AUTHORED SB ONE- WE CERTAINLY
WOULD WANT TO SEE THIS FOLDED
INTO A KIND OF THE FOR THE
BROADER WORK THAT'S HAPPENING
UNDER SB ONE AND THEY THEY
CERTAINLY OPEN TO THAT. I'M SO.
WE'RE TAKING ANOTHER RUN AT
WE'RE IN IT WE'RE GONNA. HAVE
OUR DOORS ARE WIDE OPEN TO THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE TO. ADDRESS
WHATEVER CONCERNS OR NEEDS THEY
THEY MAY HAVE A LONG IN THE
WITHIN THE SPIRIT OF WHAT CENTER
LAYER JUST DESCRIBED. WE THINK
WE'VE WE- IN CLOSE COORDINATION
WITH THE COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE
THAT WE'VE- WE CHANGE IT IN
ENOUGH. THAT THE- YOU KNOW THAT
AND WE'VE BEEN THINKING ABOUT IT
ENOUGH THAT THAT THEY- WILL.
WILL FEEL COMFORTABLE WITH WHAT
WE HAVE BUT WHAT'S BUT WE'RE
VERY OPEN BOTH TO. SUGGESTIONS
FROM HIS OFFICE AND FROM YOUR
SENATOR. I TOOK TO GET A CLOSER
TO. ENOUGH TO. PRIME TIME SO
FEEL. SIGNING IT. OKAY WE ARE
MOST CENTER LAYERED ANY OTHER.
OR QUESTIONS- C. NINE. THEIR ON
YOUR CLOTHES YEAH. SHE
DISCUSSION AND APPRECIATE
EVERYONE'S EMPLOYED. LOVE TO
WORK WITH YOU AS WE CONTINUE
MOVING THIS IMPORTANT POLICY FOR
THEM PERSPECTIVE YESTERDAY ABOUT
. VERY GOOD- SO THE MOTION IS-
IS YOU PASS TO HAVE AMENDMENTS.
YEAH I KNOW I KNOW THAT YOU
THINK- GIVEN THE SOME TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS AND WE THESE ESSEX UP
OKAY VERY GOOD SO IT'S JUST AS
AMENDED AND RE TO
APPROPRIATIONS- TO CANCEL THESE
HOLLOW FILE ITEM SO S. B. TEN
SEVENTY EIGHT THE MOTIONS TO
PASS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
STERN STERN ALL RIGHT JONES.
ALLEN ALLEN RIGHT EGGMAN. EGGMAN
RA GROVE HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG
HIGHWAY SO HUESO LAYERED HI
LAYERED AYE LIMÓN MON ALL RIGHT
OKAY THAT MEASURE IS SEVEN- I
VOTE ZERO NO VOTES- THE MEASURES
THAT WILL CLOSE THE ROLE THERE-
SO OUR FINAL ITEM TO THE SAID-
TODAY- FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN- SB
TEN TWENTY SEVEN ATKINS THEIR
HUESO UNDERSTAND YOU'RE GONNA
PRESENT- THE PRO TEM STOOD HERE.
OKAY PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
SB TEN TWENTY SEVEN IS A PRETTY
STRAIGHTFORWARD BILL- IT'S A
BILL THAT PERTAINS THE SENDING
RIVER CONSERVANCY. AND THE
RESTORATION THE CONTINUED
RESTORATION AND MANAGEMENT OF
THAT RESOURCE. THE SENEGAL RIVER
CONSERVANCY WAS ESTABLISHED IN
TWO THOUSAND TO. COOL AND IT AND
IT'S BEEN ON AN ON GOING
RESTORATION. PROJECT AS YOU KNOW
SAN DIEGO RIVERS ONE OF
SENEGAL'S MOST IMPORTANT RIVERS
SUCH AS- OF. THE HUMAN LIFE
RECENT EVIDENCE OF SUCCESS OVER
A HUNDRED THOUSAND YEARS IF YOU
CAN BELIEVE THAT- BUT IT'S BEEN
A VERY IMPORTANT RESOURCE FOR
THE NATIVE AMERICAN. THE FIRST
CALIFORNIA MISSION WAS
ESTABLISHED- ON THE RIVER. I
THAT THAT IN THAT'S PER OF A
CALIFORNIA'S OF OUR HISTORY IT'S
A VERY IMPORTANT RIVER FOR THAT
RE- FOR MANY REASONS- SB TWELVE
AT TEN TWENTY SEVEN ADDS ONE
REPRESENTED FROM THE ALCOHOL IN
CITY. TO THE CAN GOVERNING. AND
ALSO REDUCES THE NUMBER
REPRESENTS FROM CITY OF SAN
DIEGO FROM ONE TO TWO. AND THAT
IS JUST TO PROVIDE A
GEOGRAPHICAL OF FAIR
GEOGRAPHICAL REPRESENTATION IN
THE ARREST. OF THE RIVER. THIS
RIVER AND ITS TRIBUTARY. US
ACROSS THE COUNTY UP INTO THE
MOUNTAINS AND WE WANT TO ENSURE
THAT THE- NEIGHBORING
COMMUNITIES THAT A BUT- THE
RIVER ARE GIVEN PROPER
REPRESENTATION TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE CORPORATE RESOURCES IN THE
RESTORATION EFFORT I JUST.
EQUALLY AMONG THE RIVER THAT
EVERYONE HAS AN EQUAL SAY IN
ALSO GIVEN- THE INCENTIVE TO
WORK ON THE ROOF RESTORATION OF
THIS RESOURCE ON BEHALF OF
CENTER. I ASKED YOUR AYE VOTE SO
IMPORTANT MEASURE THANK YOU SO
MUCH- WE NOW GOING TO TURN- THE
WITNESSES AND- I KNOW WE HAVE A
WELL HEELED. MISTER CLAY FROM
THE COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO HERE.
WORKING VERY HARD THIS MORNING
WELCOME AND ENJOY MY FIRST A
TRIP OVER TO THE NEW HEARING
ROOM SO- JOHN MCCLAIN BY FOR THE
COUNTY SAN DIEGO- THE COUNTY IS
WORK CLOSELY WITH THE SAN DIEGO
RIVER CONSERVANCY SINCE ITS
INCEPTION- WE APPRECIATE THE
EFFORTS BY- CENTER ACTIONS ON
THE CHANGES SHE'S MAKING WE
THINK. SWITCHING TO WATERSHED
BASED APPROACH MAKES SENSE YOU
LAMINATE IF YOU LOOK TO THE
ANALYSIS THERE'S ALSO THE LITTLE
DONUT HOLES. WITH THE CURRENT-
SET UP OF HALF MILE FROM THE
BOUNDARIES OF THE RIVER- WE ALSO
THINK IT MAKES SENSE INCLUDE THE
CITY HOME THAT IS FULLY WITHIN
THE BOUNDARIES OF THE SAN DIEGO
RIVER. AND WITH THAT WE JUST
APPRECIATE THE CHANGES AND LOOK
FORWARD TO- THE MEASURE. MOVING
FOR THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
. MISSED CITIES ILLEGAL WELL
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MORE TOP ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF SAN DIEGO WE TOO ARE HERE IN
SUPPORT- AS NOTED IN YOUR
ANALYSIS THE- CITY OF SAN DIEGO
HOLDS- TITLE TO A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT. OF THE WATERSHED- AND WE
THINK THIS BILL BY EXPANDING
INTO A FULL WATERSHED- IS
APPROPRIATE- IT MAKES A WHOLE
LOT OF SENSE IT WAS KIND OF.
GEOGRAPHICALLY ODD THAT IT WAS
NOT- INCLUDED- IN ITS ENTIRETY
PRIOR. WE THINK THAT THE CHANGES
WILL IMPROVE- EQUITY AND-
IMPROVE PARTNERSHIPS THAT WE
HAVE THROUGHOUT THE WATERSHED.
I'M AND WILL REALLY TAKE A AN
ALREADY- WELL FUNCTIONING
CONSERVANCY- INTO AN EVEN BETTER
PLACE SO WE ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SO MUCH- NOW
TURN TO OTHER WITNESSES- GENERAL
WITNESSES WISHING TESTIFIED
SUPPORTING HEARING ROOM SEEING
NINE MODERATORS TRYING TO
LINE'S. JOB ANYONE WISHING
TESTIFIED IN SUPPORT OF SB TEN
TWENTY SEVEN NAME. POSITION AND
AFFILIATION. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF SB TEN TWENTY SEVEN
YOU MAY PRESS ONE. AND THEN ZERO
THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF SB
TEN TWENTY SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS
ONE. AND THEN ZERO. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. MY THIRD SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN SENATORS FOR SOME
HAPPEN NATURE CONSERVANCY AND
SUPPORT OF THE PROTONS SB TEN
TWENTY SEVEN THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT. THERE ARE NO FURTHER LINES
SUPPORT OF SB TEN TWENTY SEVEN.
VERY GOOD I NOW WILL TURN TO
WITNESSES WHICH DESPITE
OPPOSITION ARE THERE ANY IN THE
HEARING ROOM SEEING NONE. WILL
TURN TO THE MODERATOR PLEASE
QUEUE UP ANYONE WAS DESPITE
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH
TO COMMENT IN OPPOSITION OF. SB
TEN TWENTY SEVEN. YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION OF S. B.
AND TWENTY SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN DINNER. WE HAVE NO
LINES IN OPPOSITION SB TEN
TWENTY SIX OKAY VERY GOOD-
SEEING NO FURTHER OPPOSITION-
WILL BRING BACK TO THE DYESS-
CENTER LAYERED. I WOULD JUST SAY
THAT WE SPOKE TO THE THREE BILLS
EARLIER ALL OF WHICH THAT
EXPAND. OUR BOUNDARIES OF
SMALLER CONSERVANCY'S THIS IS A
GOOD BILL- I WOULD MOVE TO BILL
. MOTION FROM SENATOR LAYERED AS
SENATOR JONES THANK YOU- OUR
QUESTION FOR EITHER THE AUTHOR
OR FOR- MISTER CLAY- AS THIS.
EXPANSION HAPPENS. WE ARE
EXPANDING RECREATIONAL POTENTIAL
NOT CONSTRAINING IS THAT CORRECT. YES THE RIVER IS USED WE WANT
TO RESTORE RECREATIONAL ACCESS
TO THE RIVER WE WANT TO USE
DEPARTMENT OF PROTECTION WE
WANNA WE WANNA MAKE IT A LIVING
WATERSHED WITH ALL THE BENEFITS
OF THAT THAT COULD PROVIDE. AND
INCLUDING I MEAN RECREATION
WHICH IS YOU KNOW YOU KNOW THAT-
SAN DIEGO RIVER IS A VERY
IMPORTANT RECREATIONAL RESOURCE
AND WE WANT TO KEEP THAT ALIVE
AND THAT'S THE WHOLE POINT OF
OUR WATERSHEDS CAR PARKS. AND
ARE NOT NATURAL AREAS THEY
SUPPORT THE ENVIRONMENT AND
ALSO- OF. THE WHOLESOME-
COMMUNITY BENEFITS. THANK YOU
WELL AS A FORMER MEMBER OF THE
CONSERVANCY AND- I THINK THE
ENTIRE WATERSHED EAST OF SAN
DIEGO THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO IS
IN MY DISTRICT- SOME THINKING AS
I'M LOOKING AT THE MOUNTAIN
RANGES IN MY MIND. I THINK MAYBE
SOME OF IT GOES INTO YOUR
DISTRICT AS WELL SO I'VE
CERTAINLY SUPPORTED I THINK IT'S
A GREAT IDEA AND- LOOK FOR TO.
SUPPORTING PROCESS. VERY GOOD I
THINK THERE JONES ANY OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS BEFORE WE
LET THE OTHERS CLOSE SEEING
NONE. THERE WAS A TACTFULLY ASK
YOUR SUPPORT. FOR THE SUPPORT
MEASURE. THANK YOU SO MUCH- SO
THE MOTION IS. A DO PASS AS
AMENDED THE FIRST AMENDED RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CHIEF CONSULT
WHICH PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. FILE
ITEM TENNIS BE TEN TWENTY SEVEN
MOTIONS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. ALL RIGHT STERN
ALRIGHT JONES. JONES AYE ALLEN.
ALLEN HI EGGMAN. EGGMAN ALL
RIGHT GROVE HERTZBERG AYE
HERTZBERG HIGHWAY SO. HUESO ARI
LITTERED HI THERE I ALONE. MON
ALL RIGHT OKAY THE MEASURE AS
EIGHT VOTES IT'S OUT- WILL TURN
BACK TO THE OUTSTANDING ITEMS
LEFT ON CALL I BELIEVE IT IS
ONLY THE- CONSENT CALENDAR-
UNTIL WE LOOK WITH THE CALL ON
THE CONSENT CULTURE CHIEF
CONSULTANT. ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR JONES. JONES HI. GROVE
LIMÓN. MON HI. OKAY THAT
MEASURES OUT AND- WITH THAT. WE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR FOR YOUR TIME
IN THIS MEETING IS HEREBY
ADJOURNED.